dado que gm x es igual a 8 x2 encuentra
g de 0 g de menos 5 y 12 x + 3 muy bien
estoy acá es lo único que podría
aparecer un poco raro pero básicamente
no se están definiendo una función y una
función consiste en que a un cierto
valor x lo metemos en la función que
podemos pensarlo como una caja aquí está
la función g
y de ahí obtenemos un valor a cambio en
este caso resulta que el valor que
obtenemos es el 8 x + 2 o sea
multiplicamos el número por 8 y le
sumamos 2 muy bien entonces si aquí
metiéramos el 1 digamos que teníamos que
hacer tengamos que meter el 1 a la
definición de g en todos los lugares
donde aparece x lo cambiamos por 1 así
que nos quedaría 8 por 1 que es 8 más 2
más 2 812 es 10 entonces aquí saldría un
10 vale aquí saldría un 10 ok con eso
dicho vamos a encontrar que de 0 g de
menos 5 g de 2 x + 3 déjame empezar con
g de 0
voy a poner con colores para que sea un
poco más claro entonces queremos
determinar g g de 0 vale entonces este
este es el que voy a hacer ahorita como
le hacemos para determinar g de 0 pues
en todos los lugares donde aparezca x en
la definición de g
tenemos que cambiar esa x por un 0
entonces nos quedaría 8 x 0 x 0 que voy
a poner en color rojo mejor ya eso
tenemos que sumarle dos más dos vale
aquí ya podemos hacer las operaciones 8
por 0 es cero cualquier cosa por
cervecero esto se hace cero sea cero le
sumamos 2 nos quedan dos vale entonces
déjame escribir por aquí al lado kg de 0
g de 0 es igual a 2
vamos con g de menos 5 g5 déjame hacerlo
con este color rosa va entonces nos
piden determinar g de menos 5 muy bien
misma idea cada vez que tengamos una x
hay que cambiarla por un -5 y entonces
nos quedaría 8
x y aquí tendríamos que poner el menos 5
x menos 5 ya eso tenemos que sumarle dos
más dos cuánto nos queda 8 x menos 5 es
menos 40 a esto tenemos que sumar 2
menos 40 más 2 es igual a menos 38 y por
lo tanto g de menos 5 de menos 5 es
igual a menos 38 muy bien entonces esto
fue el segundo problema vamos al tercero
que se ve un poquito más interesante
mira nos piden determinar g de 2 x + 3
ahora no tenemos un número sino que
tenemos toda una expresión cómo le
hacemos para esto pues mismísima idea es
más déjame poner un ejemplo un poco más
extremo qué pasa si nos piden determinar
g g de círculo naranja
esto va a ser un poco raro pero espero
que veas la idea si nos piden determinar
g de círculo naranja básicamente tenemos
que hacer lo mismo cada vez que aparezca
una equis la tenemos que cambiar por un
círculo naranja entonces sería 88 x un
círculo naranja esto está como raro
verdad pero bueno es la idea y a eso
tenemos que sumarle 2 si tuviéramos una
estrella sería 8 por estrella más 2 como
aquí tenemos un 2 x + 3 que déjame
ponerlo con este color verde claro como
tenemos un 2 x + 3 tenemos que cambiar
todas las x por 2 x + 3 entonces que es
de 2 x 3
2 x 3
es igual es igual a 8 x lo que valga
equis y a eso tenemos que sumarle 2
déjame hacer un poco más de espacio
tenemos que sumarle 2 entonces que va
aquí adentro pues va el valor de x pero
ahora tenemos la expresión 2 x 3
entrando a la función de entonces
tenemos que poner aquí 2 x 3 sería 8 x 2
x + 3 y cuánto nos quedarían pues haber
8 x 2 x es 16 x 16 x 3 x 8 es 24 y
también tenemos que sumar este 2 más
no voy a poner así más 2 y entonces que
nos quedaría nos quedaría 16 x + 26 16 x
+ 26 déjame reescribirlo aquí
de 2 x 3 2 x 3 es igual a 16 x + 26
entonces este último inciso pudo
resultar un poco complejo o confuso pero
la idea es muy sencilla simplemente
cualquier cosa que tengamos aquí aquí es
2 x + 3 tenemos que sustituir la x x y
eso es un poco raro cambiar una
expresión que tiene x por x por esta x
verdad como que parece algo extraño pero
es básicamente esa idea así aquí tendría
si aquí tuviéramos un triángulo sería 8
x triángulo + 2 si tuviéramos una luna
sería 8 x una más 2 y eso es exactamente
lo que hicimos simplemente sustituimos
lo que está adentro del paréntesis en
donde estén todas las x